[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
schönen montagabend ihnen alle mit mir
im studios kristin otto für den sport
vor allem fußballer guten abend und
unter anderem das haben wir heute für
sie vorbereitet
debatte über schwere waffen für die
ukraine in deutschland erhöht die union
den druck auf die ampel während
ranghoher us-vertreter in kiew neue
militärhilfe zu sagen
erleichterung und sorge in europa der
wahlsieg von emanuele makro lässt viele
länder aufatmen das plus an stimmen für
die rechte marine le pen nicht
risikofaktor weizen mangel die
weltmarktpreise galoppieren weiter nach
oben und gefährden in ärmeren ländern
wie dem libanon zunehmend die stabilität
[Musik]
morgen internationales treffen auf dem
us-luftwaffenstützpunkt ramstein es geht
um die verteidigung der ukraine cdu und
csu setzen die bundesregierung
diesbezüglich unter druck die union
möchte dass der bundestag noch in dieser
woche darüber entscheidet ob schwere
waffen geliefert werden sollen und hat
einen entsprechenden antrag formuliert
aber die regierung ist in dieser frage
weiter uneins thomas reichert den
schützenpanzer marder hätte die ukraine
gerne im kampf gegen russland sind
version 100 ausgemusterte panzer wie der
rüstungskonzern rheinmetall nun
einsatzbereit machen und in den
kommenden monaten liefern berlin müsste
das genehmigen und reagiert heute
schmallippig wie schnell wie die
regierung entscheiden würde ich sagen
jetzt zeitnah
wie sehr der marder antrag die ampel in
bedrängnis bringt zeigt dann nachmittag
die spd vorsitzende deren antwort zwar
ausführlicher ist aber noch distanziert
hat da verfolgt natürlich jetzt auch ein
rüstungskonzern seine eigenen seine
eigenen interessen und gibt jetzt
bekannt was
lieferfähig wäre wir werden uns damit
beschäftigen müssen ganz klar ist aber
dass vorrang jetzt der ringtausch hat
ringtausch bedeutet dass osteuropäische
staaten schwere waffen liefern meist aus
sowjetzeiten deutschland für ersatz
sorgt aber eben nicht selbst liefert ein
minimalkonsens in der ampel der
opposition reicht das nicht es geht zum
einen um das symbol dass wir
unterstützen und zweitens geht es jetzt
wirklich darum den krieg nicht weiter zu
verlängern die union will nun die gegner
von schweren waffenlieferungen in der
ampel unter druck setzen in einem antrag
fordert sie unverzüglich über angebote
aus der sicherheits und
verteidigungsindustrie zu entscheiden
material und waffen aus firmen hand
darunter schwere waffen die gepanzerte
waffensysteme sowie artillerie systeme
in kürzester zeit an die ukraine zu
liefern die ampel hält dagegen wir
werden einen eigenen antrag als ampel
machen und in den deutschen bundestag
einbringen über all das was wir für die
ukraine tun und die union ist herzlich
eingeladen darüber zu verhandeln so
versuchen olaf scholz und die ampel
geschlossenheit zu wahren während
gleichzeitig in und außerhalb der
koalition der druck wächst nun auch
selbst schwere waffen zu liefern
und da müssen wir nachfrage bei schalke
unterlag energy in berlin wie
problematisch könnte das für olaf scholz
und die regierung werden ja das könnte
sehr problematisch werden es könnte
sogar der zweite parlamentarische
offenbarungseid nach der impfpflicht
werden nach der gescheiterten damals und
wir sehen momentan ist die
koalitionsparteien in der frage der
waffenlieferungen tief gespalten sind
fdp und grüne wären bereit mehr zu tun
auch über schwere über die lieferung
schwerer waffen zu reden saskia esken
hat für die spd heute noch einmal gesagt
panzer lieferungen aus deutschland
stünden überhaupt nicht zur debatte und
in diese lücke stößt jetzt die union mit
ihrem antrag und wird die ampel damit
dazu zwingen farbe zu bekennen wir haben
es gerade schon gehört die ampel
parteien arbeiten an einem eigenen
antrag um die eigenen reihen
zusammenzuhalten die frage ist nur wie
man die gräben die sich da eben gezeigt
haben zuschütten möchte überbrücken
möchte ob der ringtausch dafür ausreicht
um die kritischen stimmen aus den
eigenen zu beruhigen und sie davon
abzuhalten für den unions antrag
zustimmen dass es jetzt noch völlig
unklar morgen werden wir dazu
wahrscheinlich mehr hören da gibt es
einen koalitionsausschuss und da wird
sicherlich noch immer weiter darüber
beraten chakra dankeschön nach berlin
das wird also eine spannende woche in
berlin russland bleibt auf
konfrontationskurs nicht nur in der
ukraine moskau weist 40 deutsche
diplomaten aus eine vergeltungsmaßnahme
für einen ähnlichen schritt berlins
zuvor in der ukraine halt der besuch von
us aussenminister blinken und
verteidigungsminister aus denn nach er
also ist der besuch war der erste seit
kriegsbeginn christoph distel mit mehr
irgendwo in polen an der grenze zur
ukraine zwischen paletten und
journalisten dürften die beiden us
minister den schleier über ihre geheime
reise gestern von der jetzt die welt
erfahren soll
nachträglich werden noch bilder vom
treffen in kiel freigegeben die
herzliche begrüßung fast zur
kernbotschaft der amerikaner
wir sind zurück und der grund dafür sind
sie herr seeh lenski ihr
außergewöhnlicher mut und ihr erfolg
beim kampf gegen diese entsetzliche
russische aggression
beide minister unterstreichen russland
sei geschwächt die ukraine könne diesen
krieg gewinnen
was sie geleistet haben um die russen
bei kiew zurück zu schlagen war
außergewöhnlich wir sind hier um sie auf
jede mögliche art zu unterstützen
doch vor einem schrecken auch die usa
zurück schwere waffen panzer oder gar
kampfflugzeuge wollen auch sie nicht
direkt abgeben aber noch mal mehr
munition etwa und noch mal mehr geld
niemand hat uns finanziell so sehr
unterstützt in die usa 3,4 milliarden
für waffen dafür möchte ich danke sagen
von da wo das meiste geld hinfließt vom
krieg an der front gibt es auch heute
kaum bilder es heißt im umkämpften
donbass versuche die russische seite an
vielen stellen richtung westen
vorzudringen oft mit artillerie selten
wie im umkämpften partner auch mit
bodentruppen in der fast völlig
zerstörten kleinstadt seien sie
zurückgeschlagen worden meldet die
ukrainische armee aber nicht nur da
allein in den regionen donetsk und
johanns wurden sieben feindliche
attacken zunichte gemacht indirekt
bestätigt dass auch der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
kein wort in seinem täglichen berichte
über gebietsgewinne wo sonst jeder
erfolg genau verbucht wird für die
eingeschlossenen im stahlwerk von mario
pohl hatte moskau heute eigentlich
feuerpause und flucht korridor in
aussicht gestellt es wurde nichts daraus
die lage der menschen in den kellern
wird täglich aussichtsloser
wir sprechen jetzt mit unserem reporter
dara hassanzadeh er ist in mikro die
stadt mit fast einer million einwohnern
liegt rund 250 kilometer westlich von
der frontlinie bei bonn jetzt da was
können sie uns zur aktuellen situation
sagen
die industriemetropole dnipro die ist
ein drehkreuz zum einen für die vielen
flüchtlinge aus der ost ukraine zum
anderen aber für den nachschub für die
ukrainische armee speziell für die
südöstliche frontlinie das weiß aber
auch russland und hat die angriffe auf
die infrastruktur in letzter zeit erhöht
allein sei der in den letzten 24 stunden
gab es fünf bombardements auf güter
bahnhöfe
dabei kam es zu toten der krieg in der
ost ukraine
er findet den weiten teilen auf offenem
gelände statt umso wichtiger ist eine
funktionierende logistik der nachschub
das gilt allerdings für beide seiten und
bisher war dass der nachschub nicht die
stärke der russischen armee live aus
nico war das daran hassanzadeh vielen
dank
nach seinem umstrittenen new york times
interview fordert spd chefin esken ex
kanzler schröder zum parteiaustritt auf
schröder agiere seit jahren nur noch als
geschäftsmann man soll aufhören ihn als
elder statement als altkanzler
wahrzunehmen so esken im deutschlandfunk
die parteispitze hatte schröder zuvor
vergeblich aufgefordert seine mandate
bei russischen energiekonzernen
aufzugeben
im vergangenen jahr also schon vor dem
russischen angriff auf die ukraine sind
die weltweiten militärausgaben das
siebte mal in folge gestiegen weltweit
floss die rekord summe von mehr als zwei
billionen dollar in rüstung so das
friedensforschungsinstitut sipri am
meisten haben die usa china indien
großbritannien und russland ausgegeben
deutschland belegt hinter frankreich
platz sieben
frankreich bleibt politisch auf
proeuropäischen kurs präsident marco hat
sich ja in der stichwahl gegen seine
rechte herausforderern le pen
durchgesetzt er erhielt rund 58 prozent
der stimmen in seiner siegesrede sagte
er er wisse dass viele nur für ihn
gestimmt hätten um die rechtsextremen zu
verhindern le pen holte mit fast 42
prozent das bislang beste ergebnis ihrer
partei christel haas
dieser kleine ort in südfrankreich ist
das symbol für ein gespaltenes land 50,1
prozent für makro 49,9 firmen
hält westen ukraine krieg und cupid
makro hat das alles gut gemacht
die wichtigsten dinge fürs leben sind
teurer geworden ich hätte mir einen
wechsel gewünscht ich habe keine angst
vor marin ich hoffe dass man die lehren
aus dem ergebnis zieht und mehr an die
ärmel menschenwelt
firma chronist es ein sieg mit einer
bitteren note denn er weiß dass viele
ihn nur gewählt haben um die
rechtspopulisten zu verhindern
diese neue ära wird nicht die
fortsetzung der letzten fünf jahre sein
wir werden alle gemeinsam eine andere
politik erarbeiten eine für fünf bessere
jahre und im dienst unseres landes
28 prozent der wahlberechtigten haben
sich enthalten vor allem die jungen das
ist ein rekord makro steht vor einer
riesigen herausforderung er muss
denjenigen etwas anbieten die ihnen nur
zähneknirschend ihre stimme gegeben
haben und denjenigen die sich enthalten
haben stichwort klima und kaufkraft darf
aber gleichzeitig seine eigene
wählerschaft nicht vor den kopf stoßen
es ist ein schwieriger spagat und dann
ist da marie le pen die ihr bestes
ergebnis eingefahren hat und die schon
wieder in die zukunft blickt in richtung
der parlamentswahlen im juni im gleichen
atemzug mit dem eingeständnis ihrer
niederlage hat er sie gestern verkündet
dass sie nicht aufgeben wolle und für
eine starke opposition im parlament
kämpfen werde
das ist die nächste hürde die im makro
nehmen muss er braucht dort eine stabile
mehrheit um überhaupt etwas verändern zu
können
wahlen auch in slowenien da hat die
liberale partei des politischen
quereinsteiger und energiemanagers
robert und gelobt überraschend deutlich
die parlamentswahl gewonnen clubs
freiheitsbewegung kam nach auszählung
fast aller stimmen auf
35 prozent die sozialdemokraten gelten
als wahrscheinlicher koalitionspartner
der rechtsnationale ministerpräsident
janez jansa holte 24 prozent
mehr als vier jahre lang saß der
türkische kulturförderer osman kavala in
untersuchungshaft jetzt wurde er von
einem istanbuler gericht wegen
versuchten umsturzes der regierung zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt kavala ist
ein reicher unternehmer der sein geld in
eine kulturstiftung investiert hat die
unterstützt
bürgerrechtsorganisationen fördert unter
anderem kulturprojekte für kurden oder
setzt sich für die türkisch-armenische
versöhnung ein jörg brase berichtet
osmán kabbala anhänger standen vor dem
gerichtsgebäude und konnten es nicht
glauben
lebenslang für den kunstförderer kavala
wegen unterstützung eines
umsturzversuchs unbegreiflich für seine
freunde und anhänger ein schock auch für
die deutschen organisationen die
jahrelang eng mit kabbala
zusammengearbeitet hatten dank osman
kavala sind belastbare netzwerke und
brücken zwischen der türkei und zwischen
deutschland entstanden die heute heute
drohen ein gerissen zu werden durch
dieses urteil
es handelt sich um ein politisch
motiviertes urteil und zeigt glaube ich
auch immer ganz stark das was man
vergessen konnte angesichts der ukraine
krise der annäherung an die eu in
letzten jahren absolut nichts ist in
ordnung in der türkei in politische
repression geht ungebremst weiter
der kulturmäzen hat er in seinem
schlussplädoyer alle anschuldigungen
zurückgewiesen bezeichnete die
viereinhalb jahre in untersuchungshaft
als unwiederbringlichen verlust seiner
lebenszeit seine einzige hoffnung sei
dass sein fall helfe die
ungerechtigkeiten des türkischen
justizsystems zu beseitigen es war ein
politischer prozess das hat der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte höchstrichterlich
festgestellt ein politischer prozess
dessen außenpolitischer schaden um ein
vielfaches höher ist als ein
innenpolitischer nutzen das macht dieses
urteil noch unverständlicher und noch
bitterer
nun wird sich zeigen ob der europarat
bereit ist aus diesem urteil
konsequenzen zu ziehen und die
mitgliedschaft der türkei aufhielt
mit anke rehlinger hat das saarland seit
heute eine neue ministerpräsidentin sie
hatte mit ihrer spd die wahl ende märz
klar gewonnen und kann sogar ohne
koalitionspartner regieren von der wahl
im saarbrücker landtag berichtet jetzt
susanne freitag
noch nie gab es im saarland eine spd
frau die ministerpräsidentin wurde das
ändert sich heute es ist anke rehlinger
großer tag tobias hans ist künftig in
der opposition
machtwechsel
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des volkes widmen lediger bekam
bei ihrer wahl sogar drei stimmen mehr
als ihre partei abgeordnete hat die
herausforderungen sind groß
arbeitsplätze gerechte bildungschancen
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
das wichtige thema pflege das sind die
wichtigsten bereiche der ehemalige
ministerpräsident gratuliert interviews
wollte er keine geben die cdu wurde nach
über 20 jahren an der regierung
abgewählt es fühlt sich natürlich hart
an das ist ein
schwieriger tag für die cdu saar gewesen
klar aber das ist demokratie ihr neues
kabinett hat rehlinger schon letzte
woche präsentiert finanzminister wird
jakob von weizsäcker er war vorher chef
ökonom im bundesfinanzministerium in
berlin beim strukturwandel will anke
rehlinger neue akzente setzen es geht
darum ein separates strukturwandel
kabinett auch einzurichten und die
strukturwandel initiative aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium in die
staatskanzlei zu überführen dort an der
staatskanzlei steht der ehemalige
hausherr zur übergabe des chefbüros anke
rehlinger kann mit der arbeit beginnen
eines hat uns der krieg in der ukraine
auch vor augen geführt nämlich welche
abhängigkeiten es weltweit gibt und wie
gerade ärmere länder darunter leiden
stichwort getreide lieferungen aus der
kornkammer ukraine bleiben aus was für
nordafrika oder den libanon ein
riesenproblem ist
bundesentwicklungsministerin schulze ist
im libanon einem land das politisch
instabil ist und immer weiter verarmt
von dort berichtet ines trams
die bäckerfamilie papin john in beirut
klagt der deutschen
entwicklungsministerin ihr leid fast 90
prozent seines weizens importiert der
libanon aus der ukraine seit
kriegsbeginn kommt kaum mehr weizen die
preise explodieren brot wird zu teuer
für die menschen und die bäcker können
kaum noch arbeiten
früher haben wir den ganzen tag über
gebacken nun nur noch vier stunden wir
arbeiten weniger und produzieren weniger
weil das mir fehlt
die ruine des riesigen getreidesilos
zwei jahre nach der verheerenden
explosion im hafen von beirut ein symbol
für den libanon von heute die wirtschaft
am boden inflation bei 100 prozent nun
ernährungskrise ein lager des
welternährungsprogramms auch das kämpft
mit den höheren kosten muss projekte
stellen im haushalt will ministerin
schulze mehr geld bereitstellen für die
folgen des krieges
was man sieht ist dass putin mit diesem
krieg auch ganz gezielt krieg mit dem
hunger betreibt also er sorgt dafür
dadurch dass eben die ukraine jetzt
nicht mehr liefern kann dass die
weltweiten lebensmittelpreise steigen
das projekt küche für alle hier bekommen
bedürftige essen das sie sich nicht
leisten können lieber hat hier arbeit
gefunden versorgt nun ihre ganze familie
die mahlzeiten müssen sie zu hause
bereits rationieren wir leben nur noch
von tag zu tag planen nicht mehr für die
zukunft ich habe überlegt den libanon zu
verlassen wegen meiner alten eltern aber
bleibe ich der weizen der ukraine fehlt
es trifft die ärmsten nicht nur im
libanon in 50 ländern droht eine
ernährungskrise
wir sind jetzt beim sport und bei der
fußball-bundesliga hat christine der
meisterschaftskampf dabei eher ziemlich
langweilig ganz anders beim
abstiegskampf und nicht mehr viel zeit
nur noch drei spieltage hertha bsc ist
schon mal ein wichtiger schritt in die
richtige richtung gelungen mit dem 2 0
erfolg im kellerduell gegen den vfb
stuttgart zumindest sportlich eine
annäherung zur versöhnung mit den zuvor
äußerst unzufriedenen berliner fans die
spieler feierten sich und diese
wichtigen drei punkte gegen stuttgart
der gang in die fankurve blieb
allerdings aus stattdessen verschwanden
die akteure direkt in der kabine als
reaktion auf die demütigung der fans
nach der 1 4 pleite gegen union sie mit
der aktion nach dem derby nicht
einverstanden und das haben sie ja
letzte woche wurde jetzt heute
demonstriert
und ich denke das ist in ordnung in
ordnung war auch die kämpferische
einstellung von magaths mannschaft davie
selke traf gleich zu beginn und in der
nachspielzeit erhöhte der eingewechselte
baye fiel auf 2 0 die hertha hat nun
vier punkte vorsprung auf den
relegationsplatz
und sehr gern der hinweis alle tore und
highlights des 31 spieltages können sie
wie gewohnt in aller ausführlichkeit
noch einmal online anschauen zu finden
auf sportstudio de und in der zdf-
heute- app
der abend der solidarität für die
ukraine beginnt morgen im zdf mit einem
benefiz-fußballspiel 17 40 live aus
dortmund der bvb gegen den ukrainischen
rekordmeister dynamo kiew mit dabei auch
nationalspieler julian klamt für frieden
gegen krieg borussia dortmund gegen
dynamo kiew das benefizspiel am dienstag
ab 18 uhr live im zdf
das amt für erleichterung in der premier
league jürgen klopp nach dem umkämpften
derby gegen den fc everton nach einer
dürftigen ersten hälfte brachte zunächst
robertson in der 62 minute gerät sind
führung und olic erhöhte dann in der 85
minute zum 2 0-endstand liverpool fünf
spieltage vor saisonende mit einem punkt
rückstand weiter auf tuchfühlung zum
spitzenreiter und titelverteidiger
manchester city erste stimmung und am
mittwoch geht schon weiter champions
league halbfinale gegen real
das wird spannend dankeschön und
christin das wetter das ist morgen
zweigeteilt im norden scheint die sonne
im süden schauer und gewitter mehr dazu
gleich von katja honnefer im
heute-journal begrüßt sie ab 21 uhr 45
wieder christian sievers so viele von
uns schön dankeschönabend und sehr gerne
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend westlich von uns hat sich
ein kleines tief ein geklingelt das
sehen sie hier an der wolken bewegung es
liegt derzeit über belgien schon am
späten vormittag brachte es heute die
ersten kräftigen schauer und gewitter
und schauer und gewitter begleiten uns
auch in der nacht hier im südwest
nordöstlich der elbe dagegen ist es klar
da bildet sich auch mal nebel und da
droht bodenfrost denn die temperaturen
sinken auf plus 2 bis minus 1 grad
richtung westen und süden bleibt die
nacht bei 9 bis 4 grad milder und morgen
erwarten uns dann in süddeutschland
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 9 und 13
grad im norden wird es milder mit 12 bis
17 grad und die 17 grad gibt's auch am
oberrhein jedenfalls am nachmittag wenn
sich dann auch mal wieder die sonne
zeigt aber in der mitte und im süden
gibt es morgen kräftige schauer und
gewitter ganz anders sieht das im norden
aus an der ostsee scheint die sonne
strahlen sonst ist es in norddeutschland
meist freundlich und dieses freundliche
wetter das setzt sich am mittwoch dann
wieder in fast ganz deutschland durch
nur in südostbayern kann es noch einige
schauer geben der donnerstag wird dann
schon wieder für alle trocken bei
temperaturen von 12 bis 22 grad und der
freitag wird ganz ähnlich guten abend